hello
conspiracy theorists and radical
freedom extremists i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message
4 11 18 20 20 november 18th
2020 we are just a week
and a day a week and a day from
thanksgiving wait is thanksgiving next
week or the week after it's the week
after
right no it's next week assuming we have
thanksgiving it's actually next week
right
we have an election that's still not
done and we've already rolled into
thanksgiving
what do you say about that all right
we've got a lot of fun stories to talk
about today because
we're mostly going to be discus
discussing the hypocrisy of the
progressives and i find that fun because
these people
say one thing and they do something else
and they're generally
pretty awful as public servants and
we're going to unpack that so the three
stories that we're doing today
aoc had a tweet from yesterday about
student loan debt
they she wants other people to pay off
your student loan debt
can not explain how she's going to do it
but you know it's just the right thing
to do
you just should do the right thing i
guess we should also be paying off
people's mortgages and
car payments and you know if you took a
little credit card loan to get a new tv
we should probably pay that off too
because you know that would be what good
people would do in aoc and the
progressives
they're very good because somehow
they've tricked people into thinking
that
envy is actually something that should
be lauded
and something that you should attain for
uh it's it's quite ridiculous so we'll
talk about that but the hypocrisy
of these people knows no bounds we're
also going to talk about gavin newsom
because as you guys know already because
this story is catching fire which i'm
glad to see he had a dinner with about
12
people at french laundry which is a
super expensive exclusive months in
advance you got to make reservations
restaurant
up in yachtville in northern cali that's
up in wine country
and uh people say that it's literally
like a thousand bucks a plate like
usually
it's 400 but you throw in a little wine
you're walking out of there for a
thousand bucks
he issued this ridiculous apology well
now some photos have come out
from the event where he kind of made it
seem like he was sitting outdoors but
there's chandeliers and carpet so that
seems a little odd and of course you're
not going to believe this guys he was
there with lobbyists
what are the chances yeah and
and if that's not enough we've got one
more from the brilliant progressive wing
of the democratic party which is pretty
much the whole party at this point
senator tammy duckworth is attacking
trump for trying to get our remaining
troops out of afghanistan
we've been in the war in afghanistan for
what like
19 years at this point something like
that 18 years
and he wants to get our remaining troops
out nobody even knows why we're there
anymore
uh but she had a just an absolutely
ridiculous quote so we've got
progressive policies that want to pay
for other people's debts
a progressive guy who's locking us down
for thanksgiving who's going to fancy
restaurants
and a progressive who is trying to keep
us
in wars it's all very very confusing
we're going to do
all of that and then of course you know
what what sits on top of this
obviously is that we're still in this
sort of election limbo everybody is
waiting
to release the kraken they keep saying
we're going to release
the kraken and sidney powell who's
trump's lawyer and giuliani
that they've got this big info and as i
said yesterday
you know the interesting thing here is
people i think want more info to be
dropped like i think people want to wake
up every day and be like oh we found out
this in wisconsin we found out this in
arizona we found out this in
pennsylvania
and that's not exactly how a legal case
uh
can come together can coalesce right
like they have to build a case i think
these are people
who know how to build a case so we'll
see if that kraken
gets released but we're not going to get
too far into the nitty-gritty
of the election today i thought i'd give
you a little break on that but before we
do anything else people
are you looking for a new protein bar
that tastes
like a candy bar you're not going to
believe it i'm holding one in my hand
right now i've got just the brand for
you
built bars are super tasty and come in
18 amazing flavors
i shared them with my family and staff
recently michael had one this morning
which is fun because everyone picked
a different flavor my personal favorite
is cookies and cream as i have right
here
bill bars are covered in 100 chocolate
include both nut and nut free flavors
and are soft and easy to chew
with the holidays just around the corner
it's easy to slip up which is why build
bars are the perfect
alternative to pie for the health
conscious guy
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein and high fiber
go to builtbar.com use promo code ruben
and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20
off at builtbar.com good for bars built
go or built boost
heading now back to me hello uh okay
let's talk about this tweet from aoc
we'll throw the tweet up on the screen
and i will read it
to you aoc things were bad for me
so they should stay bad for everyone
else is not a good argument
against debt cancellation student
medical or otherwise hashtag
cancel student debt okay so let's talk
a little bit about canceling student
debt i i find
one of the best ways to discuss this is
think about your own personal
situation so i remember when i was
applying to
colleges way back in 1993 okay
you can do the math on my age i was
applying to colleges
and i wanted to go to syracuse
university i grew up in new york
syracuse is a private school
upstate new york and i wanted to go to
syracuse university because they had a
great sports broadcast program i believe
bob costas went there marv albert i
wanted to be
a like a sports center anchor kind of
thing but i know i knew i wanted to be a
broadcaster of some sort i guess
i guess it worked out i suppose i wanted
to go to syracuse and
my dad looked at the numbers we got the
application and we're looking at
everything
and it was something like 25 000 a year
to go to syracuse
and my dad made it very clear he said if
you want to go to syracuse you're going
to have to take out the loans to do it
but if you want to stay
in state meaning go to a state school
here in new york and in new york at
least at the time
had some pretty good state schools
they're called suny state university of
new york s-u-n-y
if you want to go to a suny school which
are like 8 000 bucks something like that
will pay for it and i remember thinking
okay i can either get into a hundred
thousand dollars
debt i didn't even really fully
understand what that meant as a young
kid but i was like
a young person but i was like all right
that doesn't seem good
to walk out of school and then have to
pay all this money back right like that
almost seems like the reverse of school
school should be setting you up
so now you're ready to roll you're ready
to explode into the world and
and produce and and get and all of those
things
so i said all right i'm going to a suny
school i went to suny binghamton which
at the time was was quite a good school
they've got a bunch of problems around
free speech now and i'm
they've been trying to invite me there
to make it happen we haven't been able
to do it because of copied yet
but in essence uh my folks paid for it
it wasn't that much money and i got a
pretty solid education i was a political
science major so maybe something got
through to me
and although i was a progressive for a
while after that so i'll have to rethink
that one but
the point is everyone in their life
makes choices
so i chose not to get a hundred thousand
dollars plus into debt now
syracuse university at the time as i
said was about 25 grand right now
syracuse university 54
000 a year without
food or housing with food or housing
they estimate
that it will be 75 000
per year to go to this college now i
don't even need to comment on syracuse
university as a university specifically
75 times four let's do the math here
people that's about 300 grand that means
if you're taking out loans
to go to syracuse university to be
whatever it is that you want to be
you walk out of that university in the
hole for 300 grand
now even if you get an incredible job
right after college the idea that you're
let's say you get i don't know out of
college if you've got an 80 000 year job
out of college that's pretty freaking
awesome
you're still three hundred thousand
dollars in debt and it's not like that
80 grand goes to pay that off you got to
live in everything else
anyway i mentioned all of this because
aoc's tweet which i'm just going to read
again real quick uh
why don't we why don't we throw that
back up there connor she says
things were bad for me so they should
stay bad for everyone else is not a good
argument against debt cancellation
student medical or otherwise
everyone makes choices in life and if
you
choose to go into a lot of debt well
then it's on you
to pay it off that's just the truth now
there's an irony here because the
implication this is what progressives do
with almost every policy it sort of
sounds right
cancel student debt students have it
tough young people
have it tough in this changing economy
and we should help them out well that
sort of sounds right and by the way i
think there are some ways
that you can help young people and
reduce expenses for college and are
colleges way too expensive and actually
in many cases making children
young people dumber yes they are um but
if you were to cancel student debt
first off let's think about all the
people who just paid off their debt well
they're a bunch of suckers right they
played by the rules
and now they paid off their debt and
then their tax dollars after doing the
right thing
will now go to pay off someone else's
debt so that that doesn't seem right
right there but also when you say cancel
student debt you realize aoc
that you're talking about excuse me
you're talking about a lot of
middle class and upper middle class
people who take these loans to go to
these obscenely expensive
private schools like syracuse get 300
000 into debt
and then you have in essence you're
gonna have even poorer people having
their tax money to go to pay off that
stuff so
it doesn't make sense at any level
whatsoever
um but this is just consistent with
progressives do it sort of
sounds right we don't have to think
about the second and third order of
things
but what's interesting here is she also
says student medical
or otherwise now i think there are some
arguments
as i just said about colleges that they
cost too much i think that obviously
medical bills can really add up and
there should be all sorts of ways that
we can help defray
that and i believe in competition so
that hopefully you would have
more hospitals out there that could do
different procedures because competition
actually causes prices
to drop so that's that's sort of a
separate issue but interestingly she
says or
otherwise or otherwise meaning other
types of debt
i have a house mortgage could you pay
that off for me
aoc uh i have a car mortgage
a car loan could you pay that off for me
like this this idea what it all boils
down to is they just want to say things
that outsource in essence all of your
responsibility
and they'll just take care of you and as
long as you don't fight back against
them they'll always take care of you but
then one day you might realize that
they're not as benevolent as good
as they say they are and then you're in
a lot of trouble so the
idea of debt cancellation if you've got
somebody in your family that really
thinks it's the right thing
remind them they are paying off most
likely a middle class
or upper middle class student young
person's
extremely expensive education
if you wanted to say to me hey we should
put more
tax dollars to have better public
schools that maybe aren't
uh indoctrinating young people with
identity politics and critical race
theory and the rest of it well that
would be an interesting
debate to have right i think there's an
argument for that the more libertarian
side of me says the government should
have nothing to do with it but
i actually think you know i'm the
product of of pretty good public
education i went to a
public elementary school public middle
school public high school as i said i
went to a new york state
uh college so like i think it can
work our system is now so beaten up and
and
so corroded and has had and especially
at the academic level has
had so many bad ideas infect the entire
thing that maybe it can't turn around
and maybe these things
have to drop have to just crop crumble
and collapse maybe they do
but the point is don't think that just
because someone says they're for debt
cancellation that it means
it means anything that it means that
they're good
what they're what they're really saying
is we're going to take other people's
money
to pay for someone else's mistake
and or not even a mistake someone's
happy that they took the debt out well
then let them pay it back let them pay
it back but this they love these one
blanket answers for everybody and it
doesn't really work and it
certainly doesn't work economically and
here we are so
aoc this one goes out to you yay you
ain't right on this one sister
and you ain't right on most of the stuff
uh but speaking of economics people i
want to talk to you
about glint pay you guys know i've been
talking about glenpay i actually really
love what they're doing here so glint
pay uh this is the card this is not my
actual card but it is what your card
would look like
um you can buy and sell gold on glint
pay and then you can use
the card as an actual debit card so you
can choose whether you're buying coffee
or you're buying sneakers or you're
paying for dinner at a restaurant if
you're allowed to go to a restaurant
you can choose at that moment via the
app you can choose whether you want to
pay
in gold or in dollars it's a great way
to just get involved in the gold
game so that you have something that's
backed a little more sensibly
perhaps than the us dollar which is in a
bit of a strange position
at the moment i love what's going on
with glen pay as i said i've bought
coffee i bought sneakers
um i bought some stuff on amazon there's
all sorts of stuff you can do
and again you can choose whether you
want to spend your gold
or your us dollars you can also buy gold
on there sell gold everything else
the glint card is issued by sutton bank
which is member of fdic pursuant to
license from mastercard international
it's free to sign up so go to
glintpay.comruben for more info and to
start
purchasing gold today that's
glynnpay.com
to get your gold today and now back to
me
all right let's talk about another
brilliant progressive politician so
first off we started with aoc
with an imaginary way that she's going
to pay off debt
not a real thing but she says it and she
can do it and that's a perfect segue
to gavin newsom who is our governor here
in california and he was caught we're
going to show you some of the photos
right now
he was caught at a restaurant known as
french laundry which is one of the most
exclusive expensive restaurants in all
of california
i think i mentioned a day or two ago
that i tried to go there last time we
were in sonoma and you had to have
reservations
for months and months in advance my
friend kelly rizzo who's a food blogger
i had tweeted out that it's about 400
bucks
a plate she reminded me that if you
throw in a little wine and whatever some
of the extras are you're not walking out
of there for under a thousand dollars a
plate now i don't begrudge anybody
i don't begrudge anybody from spending
their hard-earned money on these things
but you're not going to believe this
guys gavin newsom well first off he said
he was outdoors
as you can see by the pictures there
that doesn't appear to be outdoors with
giant mirrors
and chandeliers and fancy carpet that
doesn't look outdoors
nobody's wearing a mask there are 12
people there he wants you to have
less than 10 people in your own home and
you're not gonna believe it guys
there were lobbyists at the dinner here
is the quote
from politico california medical
association officials were among the
guests
seated next to governor gavin newsom at
a top
california political political
operatives
opulent birthday dinner at french
laundry restaurant this month uh it was
the ceo of the california medical
association and and some other lobbyists
that were there so
just the hypocrisy just knows no bounds
and i know
i know all politicians are hypocrites
these are people who want to exercise
power over you while they live a
completely different lifestyle
you know think back to nancy pelosi
another progressive genius
remember at the beginning of lockdown
and she's got all of this freaking ice
cream
in her twin double z fridges and it's
like i don't begrudge her that although
somehow she got really rich while being
a public servant
um but like i know that especially at
the beginning of lockdown when we were
all freaking out we were all stocking up
on food
i didn't buy any ice cream you know we
bought we bought protein we bought
rice we bought pasta um we filled our
freezer up with frozen meat and fish and
things like that chicken
we weren't just filling it up with ice
cream but she had like you know 20
different types of ice cream and she's
getting a haircut while she's telling
people not to get haircuts and mayor
lightfoot in chicago
is telling people to stay home while
she's out there celebrating biden's win
every one of these people is the worst
type of hypocrite and they should not be
in charge or have literally anything to
do
with your life you know i joked on the
show yesterday on not on my show i joked
on
i was on john john bachman's show
on newsmax and i joked that maybe i
would run for
governor of california and a zillion
people thought i was serious and then
there were there were literally
like thousands of retweets flying around
about dave rubin running for governor of
california
i mean let's let's recall gavin newsom
and then i guess stranger things have
happened but my policy would just be
the reverse newsome i would just run as
the reverse nuisance that man has a
policy my policy is the worst he's going
to raise taxes i'm going to lower taxes
he wants to lock you down i'm gonna free
ya uh he loves
just allowing homeless people to run
rampant everywhere and do drugs
everywhere
we'll we'll clean that up we got crappy
roads here i'm gonna fix the roads
i don't want to run for governor that's
literally i don't want a dime
first off i would also not take a dime
from anyone that that's for sure like i
got a youtube channel i'll get my
message out there
would i wouldn't take a dime but anyway
i'm basically kidding on this
although there is a part of me that's
now kind of like ah maybe i'll just do
it because these people are just
absolutely awful but it's just really
important to see these pictures and just
know just know that these people who are
telling you
that you have to wear masks literally
inside your house
pennsylvania announced that today they
want people to wear masks inside their
house
although they do acknowledge that it'll
be tough to enforce
but just try to imagine the level of
psychotic
authoritarian power that they want to
exercise over you
that you have friends over forget
friends you have just your family in
your house
and they think it's it would be okay to
somehow be monitoring you
what is going on here this is what the
worst sort of authoritarian regimes do
and we're being tested people
we're being tested to see how far they
can push us that's not some crazy
conspiracy theory
that's just obvious so sorry gavin
newsom i'm not going to listen to your
nonsense
i'm going to have people at my house
we're going to hug
and we're going to talk and we're going
to laugh and we're going to sing and do
all of those things
okay we just are and you can suck it all
right
moving on let's talk uh one more
brilliant progressive politician
this is senator tammy duckworth and
she had a bit of an odd reaction to
trump talking about ending the war in
afghanistan now
it's really interesting what's happening
right now because as the biden
transition team starts to leak out with
some of their invoices well it seems
like they want to reverse a lot of the
gains
that we've had in the middle east we're
not going to war there anymore there
have been peace deals signed
but now they want to get back into the
iran deal and a bunch of other stuff
we're hearing that trump who was taking
our troops out of germany
remember we're not at war with germany
anymore biden now wants to keep tropes
there
like all of the old ideas of the past
and the bad neocon ideas they now are
just
they're just have been laundered in
effect and that now they're democrat
ideas so trump has wanted us out of
afghanistan from the beginning he was
talking about it years ago
and we've been in at war in afghanistan
for almost two decades it's the longest
war in american history i mean really
think about that because nobody even
realizes we're at war there
but the afghanistan war google it don't
take my word for it it is now
the longest war in american history now
why are we there
i know the taliban and 911 and okay
all that stuff we can talk about all
that we're disrupting networks we're
getting them there so they don't get us
here
blah blah blah blah there's no reason to
be there anymore
absolutely no reason to be there anymore
so trump's trying to end it trying to
get the
troops out here's senator tammy
duckworth on what trump is doing
all of the military commanders have
spoken up and say this is the wrong
thing to do we want our troops home but
let's not bring them home in
body bags and that's potentially what's
going to happen if this president gets
his way
and puts his own political timeline
ahead of our national security
i mean the level of hypocrisy there is
so off the charts
how is getting our troops out of
afghanistan
going to cause our troops to come home
in body bags
are we going to be shooting our own
troops as they get on the planes on the
way home
i don't think so you know what would
cause more troops to die
staying in a place that we're not even
sure why we're there anymore right
every day that you stay there you
increase the risk that somebody is going
to die
if you say we are now leaving well then
less people are going to die less troops
are going to die
the way she says that that we're going
to bring them home in body bags because
of trump's timeline
by the way let's remember this one of
the reasons that barack obama became
president
a lot of people forget this but one of
the reasons that he became president 12
years ago
was because in the in the democratic
primary
hillary clinton was saying you know we
need to have some sort of sensible
withdrawal from iraq
i want to get out of iraq but it needs
to be sensible withdrawal and obama was
basically like we're leaving we're
leaving no matter what and the
and the base the progressive base was
like all right let's just get the hell
out of there now ironically
what ended up happening in iraq which is
well you all know what happened in iraq
which is that they started having
uh free and fair elections right we also
saw the pictures
and then in essence we got the hell out
of there so quick that iraq
is now just basically a failed state now
that's you can argue either way
we should have stayed longer if you
break it you got to fix it we could have
all those arguments
but the point is we don't even know why
we're in afghanistan anymore there's
just
no reason to be there and we got to get
out so
anyway the reason i wanted to do this
story is we're being
sold a lot of bad ideas that we put
away already we put the bad ideas of
endless wars away
and you know they'll tell you that trump
is this warmonger and everything else
but you know trump you know what he did
like the the two big things that he did
foreign policy-wise that actually i
think
basically kept us out of wars for the
last four years
he did two things remember right when he
became president he dropped the
[Music]
m-o-a-b
uh he dropped the m-o-a-b that was the
mother of all bombs he dropped that
thing and everyone said this is gonna
start
world war three okay and it never
started world war
iii and then he killed iranian general
solimani and everyone said this is gonna
start world war
iii oh and then he also brought on john
bolton and everyone said this is gonna
start world war three and then net
neutrality is gonna start world war
three and everything else
the guy did a couple things by dropping
this bomb saying to people hey we're
we're a little nutty we're a little
nutty you better not mess with us so
we're gonna drop this bomb and then
guess what nobody messed with us and he
took out isis
then he killed the iranian general and
everyone said you see iran's gonna
gonna go crazy now and we're in a lot of
trouble and they're gonna activate all
these supercells and blah blah blah blah
and absolutely nothing happened he
looked at the middle east deals
and said okay this isn't working right
direct negotiations between these two
parties
don't work because the palestinians
refuse to accept the deal so we're just
going to start looking elsewhere
and find countries that will sign peace
deals and they did
and now we're being told by democrats
that we have to stay
in afghanistan longer it just doesn't
make any sense and that's why i wanted
to do these three stories today
because these are the policies
of the democrats now will pay off loans
even though there's no money for it and
it's unfair to do it it's actually
anti-american in many ways
to take money from some to just give it
to others to cover their mistakes like
that's not an american
ideal okay so that was this first story
we covered the second story
you know we're gonna lock you down at
home we're gonna crush your business
destroy your restaurant
but me gavin newsom i'm gonna go out and
live like a king and not even listen to
my words and by the way
his apology if you saw the video was
absolutely disgusting he's laughing
through it
he's laughing through it he's the worst
sort of smug
awful that you got and then the third
story
where in essence they're saying more
endless wars let's just do more
more more endless wars i think that's
it's a nice package
to sort of explain the craziness of the
left and that way it got us
a little bit away today of just focusing
on the election
uh in any event guys oh i should tell
you this before i wrap up
uh i did an interview a couple days ago
two days ago with janmi park
she is a north korean defector turned
human rights activist this girl i had
met her she came here i i had some
people over for dinner i don't want to
get in any
in any trouble but i did have a bunch of
people over here for dinner a couple
weeks ago and yeah me joined
and she is an absolutely wonderful
magical human being and i interviewed
her she tells her
story of at 13 years old leaving north
korea what it was like the horrific
conditions that she lived in and
and what happened to her and being sold
into sex slavery and everything else
meanwhile she has made it to america now
and she is fighting for freedom and
capitalism
and democracy but the scary part of the
interview is she sees
some of the markings of what went on in
north korea and what went on in china
when she eventually got there
she sees some of the beginnings of that
happening here
so i just highly highly recommend you
check it out we just put up
uh part one of the interview with yon me
is up on youtube right now and you can
get the full thing
right now at reubenreport.com uh as
always thank you guys for watching
join me for tomorrow's live direct
message at 11 am pacific 2 pm eastern
don't forget to subscribe and until then
stay sane